der russische staatshaushalt erzielt
trotz sanktionen deutliches plus ist
nicht nur eine these sondern eine
feststellung ich wünschte mir diese
nachricht käme von einer russischen
propaganda seite doch die quelle ist der
deutschlandfunk muss dann halt nach
offiziellen angaben im ersten halbjahr
trotz krieg und sanktionen ein
haushaltsüberschuss von mehr als 20
milliarden euro erzielt es ist eine
bittere wahrheit die wehtut aber die
auch viele sanktions gegner früh
vorausgesagt haben hintergrund ist der
gestiegene ölpreis von dem russland
profitiert die westlichen sanktionen
haben bislang vor allem den import
westlicher waren nach russland erschwert
es gibt ökonomen die sagen dass die
sanktionen einfach länger zeit brauchen
sie brauchen noch etwas um die wirkung
zu erzielen aber wie lange soll
deutschland das noch durchhalten während
länder wie beispielsweise china oder
auch indien fröhlich weiter geschäfte
mit russland machen es ist möglich dass
wir mit den sanktionen vor allem uns
selbst schwächen
[Musik]